Randolph Ramsey you and I got to play
with project Morpheus that's right the
new sony vr thing indeed I probably
played the most entertaining demo out of
the two of us yeah so I think we said
that one to LA ok we'll talk about the
exponential demos yeah which is in a
sort of similar to the sort of stuff
we've been hearing about oculus and vibe
in which you just put the headset on and
you're in a different world yeah like
the first one I played is kind of an old
one it's you know it's that one called
in the deep hmm and it's basically you
in some sort of shark cage going all the
way down to the ocean and there's
Turtles and stuff all around you at
eventually a shock will come and attack
you oh my god and that was amazing the
second was a bit more interesting we
tried both of that that one then which
you're in the little robots that you
have in the image robots that were in
there they were in the original what
does it play room we can afflict him
Eddie or controller yeah yeah there was
two two demos in that one the first one
was virtual reality and Dualshock 4 in
your hands and you press the button in
the real life and the a bunch of rail
robots came out of it and they were
dancing on the tables and I guess the
second demo was you didn't even have a
controller you're just kind of looking
yeah basically you were looking inside I
assume it was like so supposed to be
some kids bedroom and all these little
robots around doing all their different
cool stuff there were you know there was
there was some exercising there was some
playing dance dance revolution it was
just basically like there was some wood
project more faces on their head and
they were like walking into walls and
stuff so it's basically just like you
know like a big doll house and you just
like look around and it was looked very
cool like you can be almost felt you
could just reach out and grab the little
dudes but you couldn't quite because in
all these damaged don't actually see
your body yes so the most interesting
one that was the one you did and you
have move controllers in your hand i boy
do I so I was use I have still kept on
to these and I'm happy because the best
Morpheus experience apparently comes at
using these bad boys i played this
London heist mo they're calling it it
starts off with you sitting in a chair
and there's this cockney geezer looking
at you and he's he's like kind of saying
you know where is such and such like
it's some sort of scenario where he's
trying to
get information from you and he's being
all intimidating and I was just looking
around the room and I looked over here
to like the exit sign and he did not
like that flicked his cigarette of it
like I could see it coming at a corner
of my Island they hit me above the eye
and I was like whoa and he was like
you're not getting a tma and he like
shoots I Boulud at the sign so he like
picked up that I looked at the sign
which was really interesting and then
after a couple of a minute see if it
gets a phone call and he asked me to
stand up and I like stand up and that's
when the very nice Sony man decides to
take the chair away from me which
presumably you'll have to have like a
yeah friend or your spouse doing that
for you all the time I just fall over on
it alright yeah I am and then he starts
at like he says like here's a phone it's
for you and you pick it up with your
Morpheus and you guys can use these to
like use your fingers because then
you've got these two hands and they're
moving one to one and it's crazy did it
feel right like when you reached out for
something didn't feel like it the length
you had to reach out for yes in the
world it did and I was able to like lean
forward and get in his face a bit and I
picked up his phone and then the
interesting thing was because i was
wearing headphones and it was like full
you know surround sound audio i was
basically put the phone up to my ear and
I could hear us well then if I did that
it was sounded like it was there that's
a crazy experience and that was kind of
interesting but then the next thing that
happened was now i'm standing in this
room right and the level fades and this
new one pops up and i'm standing in
front of almost like a chest of drawers
kind of situation with all these handles
I've still got my hands and I can you
know commence my fingers with these so
I'm like some guy unlike some earpiece
or whatever's timings are like looking
drawers I'm like playing them or putting
things out then there's like a bunch of
magazines for a gun in there and then
this one's got like a jewel ligo jewel
and pick up the jewel alarms go off and
the room starts getting filled up with
all these gangster dudes and the guy
says doc behind the table so I'm like oh
I'm he's telling me that he said there
must be a gun here somewhere so I'm like
literally reaching over opening drawers
I eventually find a gun then I find a
magazine and I'm like doing this I'm
like I look like it must look like it
like I look like a jerk now
in this it felt so like cool and reel em
in a waiter's I think first of all that
sensor is look it looks great like HD a
really good frame rate and and the
fidelity with the head movement on with
these was just spot-on so I'm loading
these gun and I'm acutely i think the
russian dudes when I'm when I'm went
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang and
I'm and after a while I'm like in any
other game you just shoot you chew chew
chew reload after a while I realized
every time I had to pop up to get
another magazine I was getting hurt so I
just popped up took all the magazines
put them on the floor in front of me in
this game and got there and then I'm
like diving to the side and like
reloading my gun and shooting them this
guy and we don't like a one-stage I just
dumped off so I could put a new magazine
in either say it was amazing how quickly
you you yourself into it because you
were on the floor literally at one stage
like you know shooting gangsters yeah
sideways but I kind of wanted to see if
I could break it because like the thing
would be or is that like you know you're
not moving in the world and they've made
this demo like real refined and it's in
this boxer that like you get the best
experience so I was thinking yup what
would I do in this situation I'm
probably get on the ground and try and
shoot them at the side so I tried it I
work how was a shooting great we
actually aiming did you need to aim yeah
I was I was aiming down sights when I
had a chance yeah but then sometimes I
was just like dumping like gangster
style over the top this just felt like a
completely different type of experience
like the ultimately the problem with
this thing is like how do you involve
movement how'd you get it so that the
character can actually move ran the
environments without you know putting
their controller on these or an analog
stick like I don't know how that works
but in terms of just being stationary
wiring stuff like and it did it did feel
it looked like you it was quite natural
like reaching over you you didn't have
to like no Direction twice to like open
anything you were just like
instinctively like pulling open tourism
picking up stuff you weren't
repositioning at all no and the weird
thing was like if there was ever a stage
where I guess like I my hand would go
through something it didn't it it pushed
back and then I I my body like I almost
like automatically just redirected so
yeah when I was opening in drawers i was
getting them first time they were
locking on a [ __ ] you know there was
like if you're close to it and you pull
the trigger yeah it's like you know it
knows you're trying to go for that
no I felt great and the other thing that
actually really impressed me was that
this entire time I had this big thing on
my head and I've only ever used the
oculus setting the second version not
not the latest one so might the Morpheus
is like super light and the best thing
for me is I could actually put it on
with my glasses on right because there's
a thing with oh cuz I kind of have white
glasses I can't put her on comfortably
but this was just slip it on tying a few
straps and it was great so I could
actually appreciate how good yeah it
looked in there and I'm really liking
the fact that they are starting to come
up with more game demo yeah for all of
the virtual reality stuff because all
the exponential stuff is really cool but
seeing you in that game made me think
well you know I want to get this when
this comes out like I'm excited about
what they could do with this thing if
they release the entire game and i'm not
a big like gone fan yeah but if they're
released an entire game where was
basically on Rails and you were like you
know in different scenarios hiding
behind things shooting people I would
play the hell outta it was great fun the
only things technically that I could see
that were like a little bit off was that
one I was very aware of the wire it's
not wireless especially when I was
sitting in the chairs they could
actually snagged so when i turn my head
at once a german and i have to like go
with headphones and all that stuff and
the other thing is that because it's so
light i guess it's that maybe it doesn't
have the accelerometers or something in
it i'm not sure how it works but I know
it's using the PlayStation camera and so
the room we're in was quite dark now
these work in day time I actually use
playstation move quite a lot on the on
the ps3 and these were fine in the
daytime but like sports champions or
whatever and I just hope that the
Morpheus because obviously the camera is
picking up all the lights on in front of
it that it does work in like daytime
conditions yeah obviously we're playing
in like the best possible scenario yeah
so I guess about the wait and see what
they want man who is definitely a thing
and also making sure that it is the real
world environment you get all the crap
out of the way and you'll know just
employ someone constantly to take a
chair away every time you like the
damage potential for this is wet wet
like far outweighs anything with a wii
remote you know i mean you could you can
knock your teeth you could knock the
kids or we could kill a kid comes over
you just like firing stuffy hunting a
kid across the room I guess we'll have
to wait and see Morpheus is out
apparently at second half of 26 th year
that's right yeah
I'm looking forward to seeing more of us
the stalker PlayStation Move controllers
Randy get it done